i think you put harems into like the
wrong genre then yeah i don't know
i i just most of the stories i find
really underwhelming
and i yeah i don't like some of them
i've really enjoyed
yeah some of them i don't know a lot of
them are very like generic
just get to the full but most of them
like you watch three and you feel like
you've watched all of harem like yeah
i mean oh yeah i mean for me the the
closest thing i would relate harum to
actually is that
is sports because okay here's the thing
because here's
the formula here's here's the enjoyable
part of the harem right
it's picking a team picking your girl
and then [ __ ] like cheering for her
you know this is this is about
speedrunning this [ __ ] this is about
getting [ __ ] teased about who
who the family's going to end up with
sometimes oh yeah i guess that's
that's haram sorry that yeah i was about
to say if there's only one main i was
like
yeah yeah exactly that's just a romance
at that point yeah romance i don't like
romance
but about 90 of harems you already know
wait but why don't you like romances
then because that's
that's the speed run if anything because
sometimes they just do dumb [ __ ] in it
and i'm like
no well i have to make a cohesive story
right they're not just going to be like
all right admit this goal episode 1
episode 3 i'm together
end of the end of the story sometimes
they do [ __ ] in romance then i'm like
this like okay i know it shouldn't be
realistic
but then also there's just some stuff
that's like hard for me to ever believe
whatever happened
right right i'm trying to think of a
case i can't off the table well what
about anime have you even seen them
yeah um name a bunch of iconic ones and
i'll say uh
golden time yeah called toronto i really
liked uh yeah i think i like most of
them i just never seek them out like
it's something that if a friend
recommends and i have nothing better to
do and i put it on i'll probably enjoy
it but
yeah it's not a thing that i seek out
for myself and i'm sure a lot of people
can relate to this especially those
people who watch
like only shonen like get that [ __ ] out
of here yeah uh
there was a fight scene like harem
especially i feel that most shows that
i've watched it's like oh
that's the one if if any of these girls
are gonna get it which is you know even
a mystery yes 90 of the time
nothing [ __ ] happens it's like oh the
protagonist's
a perv that's the show right
what was that one from a few years ago
where it was like they were all like
wizards
and the one guy could like counter magic
and it was [ __ ] awful
you just described like [ __ ] ninety
percent of those like
magic high school harem shows yeah and
then it'll be like it'll be like
eight eight girls and they all have one
personality trait and that's it
oh yeah the most boring [ __ ] are you
talking about index that's that's
that's that's that's what i don't see
anything like that index is the guy who
he's like he has like the right hand
that can counter like magic and
there's also the irregular of magic high
school
i love that series yeah yeah yeah i
don't know it was around that the same
season infinite straddles some i don't
[ __ ] know this guy it was
they all sound the same yeah
i'll try and find it together let's like
let's like like trying to
pinpoint an easter egg by saying what
was that one show where the guy gets
transported to the other one
yeah well i guess that it gets
overpowered yeah you know
if i find one of this it's on the screen
right now if not i'm just holding my
hands down like nicely
magic maybe that one i'll find they're
all fine
they're all cracked because it's just
garbage the thing about haram anime
is that i can never watch two at once
right because
when i'm watching two at once that's
like me watching the same show twice
but every time a new one comes on then
this time it's rent a girlfriend and
what i will say about rent's a
girlfriend is that
it's just very addicting to watch yeah
just i think and i think it's because
the main character is the way he is as
well because you
you're you're sitting there fuming but
you you click on that next episode
because you
you want us you you're like cheering for
him to become a better guy and
just to act the way that you want him to
act is it funny how it's like the
opposite of real life
you're like the moment you see people
like get out of my life
please get better come on i know you
don't come but you can do it you can do
it like imagine imagine the scenario of
rent a girlfriend
in real life you know like it's
interesting what are you one of your
mates especially in this climate
yeah exactly you find like one of your
mates is paying for like a girl
just to rent rent her as a girlfriend
and parade her around and you're like
bro that's that's that's a real broad
moment that's not that i
but like in anime for some reason i
don't know why because
sometimes there's scenarios that i feel
wouldn't work in real life
or even in like live action series but
because because it's anime and because
it's animated my
suspension of disbelief is just a bit
more so like
yeah i guess also you get to hear their
like thought process
yeah actually like you know here they
have compassion and stuff so
you can kind of simply yeah because a
live action rent a girlfriend would be
probably one of the cringiest things
you'll ever watch
yeah yeah so have you ever like
completed a haram anime to the end where
the best girl wins
oh i don't know if a best girl won wait
wait
what what n name a few famous harem
anime
[Music]
um the world god only knows the world
god only knows i watched
or to the end yeah all like three
seasons or whatever hold it down
and that was good that doesn't seem like
a show you would want no
i'm just like oh you watched that one i
watched all of it and then i was like
wait i have to
read the manga now yeah what do you mean
we have three seasons don't
stop now like that keep going i thought
normally when it gets to season three
that's normally like
all right we're in here for the long run
yeah we keep going well then it just
ended and i'm like
what do you mean what do you mean so you
showed up
so you've never gone to the end where
like there's a winning girl
where there's an actually a winner
whether it's just can't remember it
well yeah because they're all probably
generic yeah it's like again like we all
know i have monkey brain
most of the anime that's like if it's
not an eight
out of ten or higher for me it probably
is like in the forgotten yeah yeah it's
in the mere category
it's in the like okay it's good but not
good enough for me to like retain
memories
yeah no because because that's the
reason i watch haram anime
because once you watch one you basically
watch them all so to me
i love watching the same thing over
again i mean i do what you want
man after all but i don't know it's just
fun
being being in the race right and part
of the fun
is being in the community and seeing all
the salt and tears
from the losers i mean like it's like
real sport part of the fun is [ __ ]
on the losing side
very very long sports game yeah it is it
is
a 12-week long sports game right and
that's why you can get
that's why you get so invested in it
because you're you're reading this
you're reading this manga because
normally it's a manga because the anime
i can i can hardly i can
like it's really rare for an anime uh
anime harem
to actually go through to the end yeah
um so you normally follow the manga for
like weeks and weeks and sometimes it's
years
and that final chapter where your girl
wins man that's
that's like a euphoric feeling wouldn't
it i i've experienced that recently with
um
uh what the [ __ ] is it oh we never
learned we never learned yeah yeah
because they recently like ended that
and uh and best girl won and i was just
like yeah
finally thank you